do you think that there are fewer
arranged marriages now or do you think
it's just as strong as it ever has been
I think it's just as strong as it has
been so I mean I know so many people who
have an arranged marriage with again
arranged as I said is not you've not
been forced into it you meet the person
through an arranged contact and an
arranged meeting and then you take it
from there
tell us how how big can it get so of
course a wedding can get really huge and
I mean it can be can spend 7 crores
which is how many million dollars lots
but the point is that people have a
billion or two what is spending 100
million on a wedding that's a lot of
money you understand there's a hole a
wedding economy because you are not just
if you spending money it's not that it's
go you're just kind of drowning it in
notion are you providing employment you
are generating you know work for the for
the person setting up the tent the
person cooking the food is like wedding
economics you're generating so many jobs
there's only people in terms of the
clothes how has that evolved over the
years what's what's cool now ah
you know the beauty with Indian clothes
is and if you really go traditional it
never goes out of style in the sense if
you go for Indian weaves like Benassi or
or a part in patola or like very
traditional Indian leaves in epijuarez
style because it's an art form you know
it's a it's a old hundreds of years old
art form that is being woven into fabric
so that can never go out of style what's
the largest wedding that you've ever
been to i've been to a wedding with two
to three thousand guests Oh how does
that happen it happens because they're
people so people have their family then
families family then in India is this
huge thing everybody gets offended if
they not fall for our wedding so they
have to keep everybody happy so they
keep calling extended family then they
have corporate guests who would also be
offended if they not invited to an
Indian wedding